can you talk about your work as chief
scientist for the task force what did
you do did you look at material that
came in videos to analyze things of that
sort yeah so uh there were a lot of
different uh data sets that came in that
we looked at trying to figure out what
they were there were some that turned
out to be weather balloons for example
uh in fact there were several but there
were many that
there is not enough data and sensor data
we had a lot of sensor data on some of
them that uh that we couldn't determine
what they are i mean if it's our near
peers doing it that's scary uh but at
the same time we also never found any
evidence that it was our near peers
doing it right you were instrumental in
writing the report that went to con that
was demanded by congress that was made
public the 144 cases right i was one of
the people who wrote words that are in
that thing it was a team and we worked
diligently on it for a long time
and
you know we
we started out with
everything we could think of and the
kitchen sink and put in it and then
we realized it's going to a public
audience into congress and this thing so
we had to write it in a way that they
would understand and get the point and
the point the the nine pages that came
out there's the a golden nugget in those
nine pages if people would just pay
attention yeah there were 144 cases we
studied in a period of about three years
and in that time time frame of just
studying 144 cases these were only cases
that were from credible military sources
right and not from just move on or you
know because they may be having all of
the world but we picked sources that
were we knew had a chain of custody of
the day
and out of those 144
143 of them we still couldn't figure out
what they were where they came from and
what their intent was so by the time it
gets to 144 you've already weeded things
out that are easily explainable those
are legitimate mysteries that left yeah
you of course see social media debunkers
armchair experts who
take some of the videos that were
studied by the task force that are now
that we helped put out
they explain them away in a variety of
different ways it makes the military
look like idiots they have to be idiots
for to not understand what these guys
think they know yeah and that's that's
okay you know it's part of the peer
review process in science engineering uh
and but here's the thing a skeptic and a
debunker they take their results by
starting from the beginning by knowing
that the result is going to be this so
they change they take the analysis to
lead them in the direction to do that uh
i'm not here to to believe or disbelieve
i'm here to find out what's going on and
do analysis on the data we have and the
data that we had in many cases
there was more of it than what the
general public has what was released
and so when we say that we had a thing
that was from multiple sensors and it
told us multiple things and we also had
eyewitness accounts uh audio information
and so on then you put all that together
it's a much bigger picture than just
saying oh we're not going to listen or
look at any of that we're only going to
look at the what's on this few seconds
of video and we can tell you for sure
from this few seconds of video what it
is i don't think there's a person on the
planet that can really do that and do it
honestly you're an optical physicist
among your many degrees right yeah and
so you could look at an image and tell
if it's uh a flare or a bird or
something like that well i would like to
hope so
i can certainly look at it with the
various analysis tools and tell you that
if it is something as mundane as that
that's usually easy to determine uh
there are some things like uh camera
effects that that you may see camera
artifacts
will sometimes confuse someone and make
them think they've captured something
and and sometimes people will use
the a camera artifact as oh that's just
a flare in the camera or oh that's just
a bouquet effect or oh that's you know
this or that and and without really
doing the analysis you can't just say oh
it's birds don't worry about looking at
it
they also people who are describing it
as bokeh don't have other
data sources that you have that's
correct and that's one of the things
that uh people have to accept that there
is sometimes more data and you say well
then you show it to us well uh in some
cases we're not
we never had the intent to classify
things uh to keep people from knowing it
things are classified because of the
sensor
or the platform that it was taken from
we don't want to give away how we do
things right to our near peers you know
you certainly if we have a magic widget
that tell that we can say look into the
the kremlin and or something that we
certainly wouldn't want them to know we
had that magic widget right but i'm not
saying we do i'm just giving that as a
hypothetical example so
we certainly if we've got platforms that
captured other data
and it's data from a sensor that nobody
knows exists we're not going to release
that data because then you know the
sensor exists